Hi guys, good evening. Please tell me in the chat, can you hear me?
Am I audible and visible?
Guys, can you hear me?
Okay, thank you.
So, let's start in a little while.
If you have any questions or doubts, you can ask.
Guys, yesterday we shared a feedback form with you in the WhatsApp group.
So, if you haven't filled it, please do.
As I told you in the orientation session that we are running this kind of program for the first time.
So, we don't have a complete idea how to run this program.
So, the best way is to follow your feedback.
We need your feedback for that.
So, I have planned that at the end of every month, we will upload a feedback form.
And you tell us how you are feeling about the experience so far.
And on that basis, we will improve.
Just like any machine learning model.
Sir, is there any tentative course planned for the upcoming months for this year?
Yes, Harry. So, the course of LLM Ops is going on.
One more course is going on, Context Engineering.
So, these two courses are in the pipeline.
And after this, there will be one or two more courses this year.
So, assume that by the end of December, you will get four more courses in your dashboard.
Apart from existing courses.
Sir, can there be a course on LLM Fine Tuning?
Yes, Ajit. There is a plan to make it.
It's just that things are being executed in sequence.
I will try to take the course on LLM Fine Tuning myself.
So, first, once all these things are completed, it might take two to three months.
After that, hopefully we can reach there.
So, yeah.
Okay. I have a small piece of feedback. I mentioned this in the form as well.
Could you please help us learn how to read official documentation?
I finished the LLM course, but I found reading the official documentation very difficult.
If I want to build something on my own, it's hard to do without being able to understand the documentation.
Nidhi, as such, there is no different way to read documentation.
First, I can agree that reading documentation was a bit difficult because a lot of technical terms and jargon were used.
But now after LLM's Chart GPT Claude came, it has become very, very easy.
In fact, you will notice that nowadays, there is a button on the documentation pages.
Copy Markdown File.
So, you can actually copy the entire content of the documentation page.
You can paste it on Google, on Claude or Gemini or Chart GPT.
And you can start asking questions.
Whatever doubt you have, explain it in simple words and your problem will be solved.
So, mostly we use documentation because we are stuck in syntax.
So, just pinpoint the question and ask and LLM will answer you.
I do this at least.
There is no other way.
Hi Nitish, is there any job coming on LLM eval's market?
LLM eval's is not a separate job profile as such.
This is the part of AI engineering.
So, if you want to become an AI engineer, then in the process of becoming an AI engineer, you will have to learn how LLM eval's work.
Because when you make any system, then obviously you will have to make sure that you evaluate it properly first.
And when you are sure, then only you deploy.
So, you are learning the same process in this course.
Is it possible to have one course covering context engineering, harness engineering and loop engineering?
There is not a single course.
A course is being made on context engineering.
A course is being made.
We are also planning a few classes on harness engineering and loop engineering.
So, you might see a few sessions on these topics in the upcoming days.
Most likely next week or the next week.
Hi sir, Himanshu sir is also teaching deep eval in LLM ops.
And as a part of LLM eval's, you will also teach it as?
Will there be duplicacy?
Yes, there is a little overlapping.
No doubt about it.
But understand the perspective.
Himanshu will strictly teach from the perspective of Rags and maybe agents.
I will give you an overview of the entire GenAI landscape.
How LLM eval is done in the entire GenAI landscape.
So, these are like complimentary things.
Some things will obviously be repeated.
But again, I will cover things in more detail.
Himanshu will cover it when needed.
That's the only difference.
Sir, GitHub spec kit is a very popular repo.
Can we add it in our future sessions on how to leverage this?
Ansh, GitHub's spec kit is actually spec driven programming.
If you have seen my Claude code playlist, I have taught you in a video what spec driven programming is.
This spec kit is exactly the same thing.
It's nothing different.
So, there is no point in teaching separately.
Especially when there are so many more topics to teach.
So, if you watch that video, it's as good as studying this topic.
It's the same.
It's basically the same.
This spec kit was made on spec driven programming.
Okay, guys, let's do one thing.
Let's start the session.
So, first of all, I would like to apologize.
It's been a long time.
I think it's been 10 days.
It's been more than that.
My last session.
And then the problem was that I was traveling a bit.
So that is why I could not take a session on this topic.
So, from today we are resuming.
And going forward, my plan is that I consistently take classes.
At least two classes a week.
And we cover this topic quickly.
My goal is that in July we cover this topic, LLME VALS.
Completely.
So that we can move towards new topics from next month.
So, let's start the session.
Okay.
Tell me quickly if you can see my screen.
Can you see this screen?
Can you see this particular screen?
One note.
Tell me once.
Okay.
Can you see this screen?
Quickly type it here and tell me.
Okay.
Guys, so technically we have done a single class in this course so far.
If you remember.
Let me reduce it.
This course is going on on LLME VALS.
Technically we have done a single session in this course so far.
In that one session, we covered three things
Three very important things
I don't know if you have seen that session or not
I will give you a quick recap
First of all, we covered that
Why do we need
LLMEvales
Where I explained to you
with the help of certain case studies
Why LLMEvales are important
How if you
without evaluating
deploy an LLM application
in production
What can be the problems
I conveyed that point here
After that, we discussed
What exactly
are LLMEvales
What are LLMEvales
We discussed that LLMEvales
are basically systematic
and reliable way of
evaluating LLMs
or LLM based applications
against a clear criteria
I told you this definition
Along with that, I told you a very important thing
I told you that LLMEvales
have two types
One is Model Eval
and the other is Application Eval
What is Model Eval
When you
evaluate LLM
Benchmarks are used for this
And what is Application Eval
When you evaluate
your LLM application
And I told you
that this whole course will mostly revolve
around Application Eval
As an AI engineer
your time will mostly go
in Application Eval
Model Eval
generally is done by Frontier Labs
And you should know this
so that you can understand
decide what kind of LLM
you need for your application
So this was the what part
And lastly, we covered
how part where I
showed you that
how does an Eval Pipeline
look like
If you remember, I showed you this
This
This is what I showed you
how step by step
Evaluation is performed
So these three things
we have covered so far
in the previous lecture
And today's lecture will start from exactly
this point
So at this point
things are clear
So quickly say thumbs up or yes
so that we can start the session
Just tell me if you are
on the same page
It's not like there is a gap
Okay
So I will start the session
from the last line
of the previous session
So in the previous session
we were reading
So after showing
the whole Evaluation Pipeline
I told you this
last line
I told you that generally
speaking one LLM
based application
have several LLM
evals
I told you that when you make
any LLM application
there is not just one single
Eval Pipeline
Okay
With this statement
we will start our session today
Okay
So first of all I will tell you
or we will discuss
why is it like this
Why do we need multiple
Eval Pipelines
With just one
Eval Pipeline
Why can't your application
be evaluated
We will discuss this point and we will
discuss it in detail
I will give you examples and through that
I will explain you why do we need multiple
Eval Pipelines
So let me take an example
So let's say we are building a rag chatbot
for our company
or our school or college
whatever, we have a rag chatbot
What are the components in the rag chatbot
you must have missed
So what happens is there is a retriever
which is connected
with a vector database
and this retriever
retrieves the documents
and gives it to a generator
which
generates the answer
So roughly
this is the flow
Okay, query comes to the retriever
Retriever on the basis of query
from the vector database
fetches the relevant documents
and then we query
and retrieve both the documents
and give it to the generator
and the LLM
answers the question
on the basis of relevant context
This is the setup of the rag chatbot
So
Now I will tell you why do we need
multiple Eval Pipelines
One of the big reasons for this
is that in your LLM
based application
you might have
multiple
failure points
I mean to say
that your LLM based application
can be broken from many places
and there can be
failures at many places
Like if you can type in the chat
and tell me
that the rag chatbot
basic architecture I have made
what are the failure points in it
where can there be
mistakes, where the code can be broken
where there is a chance of wrong responses
Can you tell me
what are the failure points in this
rag architecture
Exactly
You got it right
If we look at it directly
we can see that there are two failure points
that can be easily seen
One is retriever, second is generator
It is possible that your retriever
fetched wrong documents
and brought them
If he fetched wrong documents
then what will the generator do
it will give wrong answers to the wrong documents
Second problem is
that the retriever is working properly
but the generator is ignoring it
hallucinating it and giving wrong answers
So we have two failure points
So obviously
these two failure points
will have to work properly
only then your application will work properly
So what you have to do
you have to put one evaluation pipeline
on the retriever
and one evaluation pipeline
on the generator
This is a simple logic
Now we will study
these two evaluation pipelines
independently
If we talk about retriever pipeline
So in retriever pipeline
What will you do
Retriever's goal is
that when it gets a query
then on the basis of that query
it
from vector database
gets relevant documents
basically
you have to
set a pipeline
an evaluation pipeline
which will
check
that given a query
are you getting the right
relevant documents
You will set up this pipeline
for your retriever
Similarly for generator
your basic
task is that you will get a context
and on the basis of that context
what will you do
you will generate answers
So here
you have to set up a pipeline
We are not discussing the nature of pipeline
we are just discussing it from above
that on the basis of given context
we will check that
whether the answer was generated properly
Here what quality are we checking
we are checking faithfulness
which we sometimes
call groundedness
Basically we will check
that whatever was given in context
the relevant documents
the answer
was generated on that basis
apart from that
no facts were created
For example if my question was
what is the duration of machine learning
course
suppose this question was asked
and my document
was extracted and written
in 3 weeks
So when the answer is generated
it should be printed that machine learning course
duration is 3 weeks
Now there should not be anything additional
that it is a great course
or you can also purchase the python course
the duration of python course
is 4 weeks
This additional information should not come
The answer should be grounded in context
So this pipeline
will check that
your context
and your answer generated
are faithful to each other
Now
see here
an important thing is
suppose your pipeline
retriever pipeline
if
just one second
I am getting a call
Thank you
Ya guys sorry
So where was I? We were discussing, let's go back and discuss again, we are discussing
that why do we need multiple evaluation pipelines in a single application. So here we discussed
that because LLM applications have multiple failure points, we took the example of RAC
and in RAC we identified that there are two failure points where failure can occur, one
is retrieval, second is generator. What we did, we put an evaluation pipeline on both
of them, okay, we are not discussing its details right now, I am just telling you that
on both of them, we put an evaluation pipeline on them. And at this point, let's assume
that these two evaluations or these two evaluation pipelines are telling us that our retriever
and our generator are working properly. So my question to you is this, what do you think?
Do you think that if our retriever is working properly and our generator is working properly,
then our application will also work properly? Is it true? My question is very simple, we
have checked that our retriever is working properly, we have checked that our generator
is working properly. So does this guarantee that our RAC application will also work properly?
You just have to answer yes and no, what do you think?
The question is simple, right? There is a RAC application, in which we have identified
two failure points, one is retrieval and one is generator. We have put an evaluation pipeline
on both of them, both the evaluation pipelines are telling us that our retriever is working
properly and our generator is also working properly. So does this guarantee that our application
will also work properly? Many people are saying yes, then some people are saying no.
Those who are saying no, can you identify from where the problem can come from? If the
retriever is working properly and the generator is also working properly, then what can be
the failure apart from this? Let me tell you a scenario. Let's assume that a user came
and asked this question, what is the duration of machine learning course? This question
went to the retriever. We had set K in the retriever, 5. Can anyone tell what K is in the
RAC? What is K in the retriever? Anyone quickly tell me. What does K equal to 5 mean?
Anyone quickly tell me, I am pretty sure you know. It basically means that we will fetch
the five most relevant documents from the vector database. Now, in these five documents,
the first document was some random thing, second document was some random thing, third document
was some random thing, fourth document was some random thing, fifth document was, which
said, the duration of ML course is 8 weeks. Now quickly tell me in the chat whether the
retriever did his job properly or not? The answer should be yes or no. It is very simple
actually. The answer to the question is very simple. If I ask this question, what is the
duration of ML course? The last document, the fifth document, clearly showed that the
duration of ML course is 8 weeks. So, did the retriever do his job properly? Forget
about re-ranking. We are not talking about re-ranking. For now, assume that our system does not
have re-ranking, so did my retriever do his job properly? Obviously, he did. When we have
given him the threshold of K, what does K mean? If K is equal to 5, then you have to bring the
correct answer in the five documents. So, did he bring the correct answer in the five documents
or not? It is like I will give you five attempts. You have to crack the exam once in five. If
you do it once in five, then my work is done. So, going by this logic, the retriever did
his job properly. Would you agree on this? That retriever has successfully worked. Am I
correct? Okay. Now, I will pick up all these five documents and also pick up the question
that I have with it and send it to the generator. I have written a system prompt in the generator
that how you will get a question, a lot of context, merge it and generate an answer. But, do you
agree that it will focus more on the initial documents? Generally, the higher retrieved
context, the generator answers on the basis of the context that is coming first. Or let's
say that your system prompt is guiding that the higher documents like D1, D2, D3, D4,
give more priority to it and answer on its basis. Right? So, what did the generator do? He
picked up something from here. It was written somewhere that the duration of the Python course
is six weeks. He took this fact and this fact and said that the duration of ML course is
six weeks. Now, quickly tell me, is this answer that came out of the track chart, is it right
or wrong? Obviously, it is wrong. But, did the generator do its work properly? Yes or
no? Did the generator do its work properly? Why no? What we had told the generator was that
based on higher priority documents, you have to generate an answer. So, what happened to
that poor person is that the documents were given wrongly. So, he tried to do his work
properly, which was on the basis of higher documents. He tried to answer. He didn't
hallucinate anything. He got six weeks of data from above. It's not that he generated that
fact in the air. It's just that he mixed up the wrong things. But, the instructions
that I had given him, he was diligently following them. So, in that sense, you can say that
the generator was independently working fine. Retriever was independently working fine.
But yet, the pipeline broke and our application gave wrong results. You are understanding
what I am trying to explain to you. I am not able to explain it to you. What we came to discuss
was that why there is a need for more than one eval in an LLM application. So, I said that
there are multiple failure points. We evaluated two failure points. But, can you see that
the workflow that is being made from the interactions between them, you will have to put an eval
on top of it. You will have to make an eval of workflow level that how the combination of
your generator and the retriever is working together. What an eval will do is flag this
error. I guess I am able to make my point that you not only need individual component
level evals but you will have to make evals on their interaction as in workflow level.
Let's say you made that eval as well. Let's say you made one more eval which evaluates the combination
of your generator and the retriever. It will tell you that what is the mistake that you gave wrong
answer. You will have to correct it. The mistake is that your correct document is at the
lowest priority order. So, most likely you will have to put a re-ranker here. The work of
re-ranker is that after the results are coming, it re-ranks them that based on the query,
the query D5 should be the highest priority. So, it will bring D5 here. D1, D2, D3, D4 will
take it down and suddenly your whole rack pipeline will start working properly. My entire
point of discussion was that if you will place evals only on the component level, then it is
not necessary that your pipeline will work properly. Individual components will work properly
but the pipeline can fail. This was the whole goal of this example. Now, tell me quickly
that suppose now your pipeline level eval is also there and it is working properly and
it is telling that the combination of your retriever and generator is working properly. So, does
this guarantee that your rag application is working properly? Does this guarantee that
you have three evals? Retriever's own eval, generator's own eval and the mixture of
these two components. This pipeline also has its own eval which is checking the working
of its combination. So, if these three evals are working properly, then can we guarantee
that our application which my user will use will work properly or is there still any scope
of problem? My simple question is that after placing these three evals, problem is solved
or can there still be any problem in this rag example where you have to write yes or no.
Augmentation eval, I mean augmentation eval is only part of generator. So, many people
are saying that yes, problem can still occur. So, can you tell where problem can occur?
My retriever is working properly, my generator is working properly, my retriever generator's
pipeline is working properly. So, where can there be problem in my rag application?
There can be problem in my rag application. There can be problem even now. For example,
one problem is that everything is working properly but in answering one question, my
entire pipeline is taking 10 seconds which basically means that my user is typing the
question and waiting for 10 seconds and then he is getting the answer. So, is our application
able to deploy in this situation? The answer is no. So, what you have to do here is that
you have to come to an application level and set eval which will check that your latency
is below a threshold. I don't know if I am able to explain it to you or not. My simple
point is that I am just trying to explain to you that where failure points exist in an
LLM based application. So, basically there are three levels where failure points exist.
I have written that down here. What are the three levels? First is component level.
Any component of any LLM application can fail. If you have written system prompt, then system
prompt can make a mistake. In rag application, retriever, reranker, query rewriter, embedding
model, vector database, if you are making a structured output based application, then
your output parser, agent, tool selector, memory, guardrails, any of these individual
components can fail. So, you will have to run eval on them. Everyone will have their own
eval pipeline. After that, if everything is going well on the component level, then also
there can be a problem on the workflow level. As I showed you a while ago, there can be
a problem in rag workflow. If you are building an agent, then there can be a problem on the
workflow level of the agent. If you are building a multi-turn chatbot, then there can be a
problem in its workflow. And if everything is going well on the workflow level, then also
you have to run eval on the entire application level. For example, you will check how much
latency is going on the whole application. Or you will check how much token cost you are
spending. Or how much time is it taking for the first token to be printed. So, you will
check these things on the application level. So, did this entire discussion make any sense
to you? That we started, why do we need multiple evals and I spent about 15-20 minutes and
tried to prove this point with an example. That's it. We didn't discuss anything more
than this. Okay, fine. Okay, let's move ahead. Now, this is one reason for multiple evals
and multiple failure points. There is one more reason and that reason is risk categories.
Okay, now what happens is that you have three things on which you can put evals. Individual
components, workflows and entire application. You can put evals on these three things. But
what is possible is that there are variations in these three things. For example, suppose
you made a Rack Chartboard. So, when a user is using that application, then obviously
what matters is that the answer that comes out should be correct. It should be helpful.
Right. That's right. But apart from this, it is also important that the answer that comes out
should be safe. It should not be that I am chatting with the chatbot and the chatbot tells me
the phone number and email of another user. So, safety is also important. Apart from correctness,
helpfulness, safety is also important at the application level. Similarly, you are talking
about any workflow. Suppose you are talking about the workflow of the retriever generator
that we have just discussed. Now what matters is that the answer that comes out is it faithful?
Is it grounded? That is one aspect. But another aspect is that the answer that comes out
should not cost much in bringing that answer. It should not cost more than a threshold. So,
this risk also matters. Similarly, if you talk about the component level, you have a retriever.
Retriever has only one job. It is to fetch relevant documents. But along with this,
it also matters that the latency of that component is how much. Now that document is fetching
correctly. But it takes 5 seconds to fetch it. It can also be a problem there. So basically
what I am trying to say is that not only you have multiple failure points but associated
with each failure point, you have multiple aspects to it which we call risk categories.
So, we broadly divide risk categories into three parts. First is the quality of the application.
Second is the safety related. And third is the operations related. Here I have written
the definition of all three. The application quality tells us that the answer that comes out
from the system is it good or not. Whether the app does its actual job well. It gives
correct relevant complete answers which the user asked. So, this is the application quality.
In safety, you ensure that the answer that comes out should not be harmful. Now, here
you see multiple things. You see that the answer should not be toxic. Toxic content should
not be there. Dangerous content should not be there. Biased content should not be there.
Private data should not leak. Or you should not be able to jailbreak it and do something
that it should not do. All this comes under safety. And lastly, what comes in operations is
whether when we deploy it, it can run fast, cheap and reliably or not. So, basically
in these three categories, we organize all the risks. So, what I have done is I have made
a kind of table where I have written all the risk categories which you will see in the future
or use when you make your own application. So, in the application, you will see that
everything that comes under safety and operational that comes under operational. You
shouldn't write all of them but you should consider the important ones that you will see
again and again, I have written them here. In the application quality, in fact, I have
organized it a little more. In normal LLM applications, what are the risk categories?
the risk categories in the risk
what are the specific risk categories
agent specific risk categories
what are the risk categories in multi turn chatbot
I have mentioned those here
for example
if you are making a general LLM application
any general LLM application
for example you are making a tech summarizer
in which you will put a big question
answer and it will
give you a summarized answer or notes
bullet point answer
that kind of application is there
what are the risks in the application
correctness and accuracy
basically what you have generated
is it accurate or not
relevance
what I asked I got an answer
related to that
completeness, all the questions I asked
I got an answer to all of them or not
instruction following
if I am specifying a particular format
or length then I got an answer
in that format or length or not
these are your core risk categories
which we will explore in this course
if we talk about rag
then the most important thing in rag is
context relevance
retriever work
the retrieval and retrieval recall
are also related
groundedness and faithfulness
means that the answer
generated was on the basis of
my context
no extra information came
citation accuracy you are getting to know
that I am able to cite
the particular line
I have written or generated
I extracted it from this particular document
you might have seen it in chat gpt
if you are making agents
then what matters there is
tool selection
is the agent able to select the right tool for the right work
or not
parameter correctness
if I am calling a tool then am I passing the right parameters or not
task completion
is my agent
able to complete the task properly
or is the failure rate high
error recovery
if my agent starts doing something wrong
while doing the task
then is he able to recover from there or not
this is also a risk category
if you are making a multi turn chatbot
where the user will chat
and the chat will keep going on
then there is a risk category
context retention
basically how much our chatbot is able to remember
our old conversation
next is clarification behavior
if our chatbot is confused about something
or if he is getting something ambiguous
from the user's side
then is he able to clarify or not
this is also seen
if we talk about safety
there are 4-5 dimensions in safety
toxicity, is the answer
toxic or not
harmful content, is there
something that should not come
such as self harm related content
weapons related content
illegal apps related content
is our chatbot biased or not
is he answering all of them
with one type or based on
user profile he is answering them separately
this is seen
PII means personal information
what happens
does anyone know what PII means
personal
let's google it quickly
personally identified information
basically
does your chatbot
or your rag chatbot
not giving out
personal information such as
credit card information or contact details
this matters in safety
lastly prompt injection
and jailbreak resistance
basically by giving prompt
you are not able to
do anything from your LLM application
which you should not do
which also comes in safety
in operations you must be understanding
latency, cost per request
token efficiency
error failure rate
latency under load
in nutshell
this is the summary of this discussion
based on these
risk categories
you create different evaluation pipelines
so same application
but there is one eval pipeline
for latency
one for safety
one for correctness
so
the discussion till now is
telling you that because of these reasons
whenever you build a LLM
application most of the times
99.99% times
you will put
more than one evaluation pipeline
this is what I wanted to reinforce
and I have given you both the big reasons
first reason because there are
multiple failure points
second reason because there are multiple
risk categories
is the discussion clear till now?
so at this point let's stop
and if you have any questions
doubts then you can ask
then we will move to the next topic
so
till this point if you have any questions
then whatever we have discussed till now
what all we have discussed
from the very beginning
why do we need LLM evals
what is LLM evals
how does LLM eval pipeline work
and why do we need multiple
LLM evals
we have covered these four points till now
so do we have
very different
evaluation metrics at each step
yeah it depends
application to application
varies, for rag application
there will be different type of evaluation pipelines
for agent there will be different type of
evaluation pipelines but one thing is sure
that there will be more than one
evaluation pipeline
any other question at this point
the main workflow too many evals
seem eval pipeline is more complex than
creating workflows
I totally agree that
at this date
making LLM applications is not that difficult
as difficult as
making perfect
evaluation pipelines
because from this whole discussion
you must be understanding that
only one single evaluation pipeline
can't capture everything
so you have to think a lot
how can LLM application fail
and to detect
that you have to make
LLM eval pipelines
in that sense yes
making evaluation pipelines and
deploying a perfect application
is very difficult
some more questions are coming
let me see
sir during retriever
in rag isn't the success criteria
or the retrieval chunks be relevant
to the questioners
shouldn't be one gives answer other
beings
actually in retriever
multiple
eval, these are the metrics
recall
precision
your reranker quality
that is also measured
so 2-3 things
rank is also important
we can use
core LLM and chat LLM if we
use chat LLM to build our app
will chat LLM not come up with guard rail
and safety as well
yes sir now see when you are using
any LLM of entropic or anyone
so
his own guard rails put in
most likely he won't produce some harmful
content but
suppose you use that
and make a rag
chart board for your company
and on your company's
documents that chart board will answer you
but
the company's rag chart board
documents coming in
there is some sensitive information of the company
so entropic
has not explained
to his LLM that
whether to give or not
it is possible that entropic's LLM
while answering
the sensitive information of your company
which he got in documents
take it out and tell
so here you have to put application specific
guard rails
that this kind of work should not happen
so guard rails don't exist only at LLM level
they exist at application level as well
in this sense you have to work on security
I hope I could answer your question
question
will any LLM
eval be there to
note if the conversation is going to
align with business or which agent
is made for
now yes
it will come under application quality
it comes under application quality
here I have not
mentioned it but
will any of these be one or
combination of these again it depends
on your business use case
what kind of agent is there
what work is being done eval is also made on basis of that
any other question guys
move ahead
on next topic
write yes
once
then
let's move on to next topic
you guys are feeling boring
I hope I didn't bore you guys
because this is all theory so
it is possible that you guys get bored
isn't it boring
I have already told you
as a teacher my biggest concern is not
whether you are understanding or not
I mean it is there
but my biggest concern is
that I am not feeling boring
because if you feel boring
then I know that you will stop
studying or your attention will go away
and then you will not pay attention
so as a teacher my first challenge is
that you don't feel boring I will explain
if you will be with me I know that
so that is why I always ask this question
first that are you getting bored
that is very important for me
ok
so
just give me one second
I will increase the font size a little bit
now the next thing
that we are going to read is very important
ok let's read
next thing we are starting
so yeah
till now we have read that
we will have to make multiple LLM evals
now
we are going to read a very important thing
which we call
methods
or LLM eval methods
basically
the eval pipeline
that you are making
on which method
will it work
we are going to read this
ok so here
there is a definition written
an LLM eval method
is the mechanism
you use to decide
whether an LLM's output is
good or not
the actual procedure that takes
an output and produces
a judgement about it
so why do we make
an evaluation pipeline
we make an evaluation pipeline
so that we can find out
that our component
workflow or application
is working properly or not
but who
carries out the evaluation pipeline
our method
ok
primarily speaking
when you make an evaluation pipeline
there is one method
out of three
first is
programmatic or deterministic method
second is human
as in human method
basically human is
carrying out the eval
and third is model graded
or you can call it LLM graded
ok
so without confusing
the way I speak
in simple words
it means that your evaluation
pipeline that you made
who is executing it
this is the point we are discussing
is it being executed by a program
is it being executed by a human
or is it being executed by an LLM
these are the three things
apart from this there is nothing else
ok if you remember
in the last class
I showed you
an LLM eval pipeline
this pipeline
I showed you
and I also told you a use case
if you remember
we are AI engineers
from Zomato
and our task is that when an email
comes we will send it
to an LLM
and that LLM will categorize
email, billing issues
technical issues
and what else
billing, technical
and general issues
we made this application
does anyone remember
which eval method
we used from these three
do you remember we discussed in the last session
we first explained
that in this whole scenario
we have to
catch the accuracy
how accurately we are able to classify
so who was calculating this accuracy
right
we got it done
through python code
so basically you can say
that it is
programmatic
so I am saying that if you make
any evaluation pipeline
one of these three things
will carry out
either program or human
or model
as in LLM will carry out
so in today's class
I will give you one example of these three
three type of pipeline
one example
I know I have given programmatic in the past
but today I will give it more relevant
one example
so
let's discuss
first of all let's discuss
an eval pipeline
whose method is
programmatic
right
we are
discussing an eval pipeline
whose eval method
is
programmatic
or what was written in the last
deterministic programmatic
so example is
that we have
thought of making
a rag chatbot for campusx
right
so that
any of our users come
so they interact with our chatbot
and get help
and we don't need to
manually reply to them through mail
right
and I thought that we have to make this chatbot
so I will make it
an eval pipeline
so
first of all I thought that
we will make an eval pipeline at component level
so
I first of all caught the retriever
and I thought
that for retriever
we will design an eval pipeline
what is the work of retriever
as soon as a question is received by the retriever
retriever
from vector database
and then
relevant K documents are
picked up
so what I have to do is
check if this retriever is working
or not
I have to make a pipeline for this
and we will make
that pipeline through this flow
so obviously
first of all
our work is
to define a task and target
our task is
that our retriever should work properly
and our target is
a single component which is retriever
next
we have to define a success criteria
that
how will we know
that our retriever is working properly
so guys
already seen on screen
but someone can tell that
how can we quantify
that a retriever is working properly
working properly with a retriever
so I told you
how do we quantify it
let me tell you
the answer is
this metric
written here
recall at K
here a definition is written
let's read it
out of all
the correct items
that exist
how many did the system retrieve
in its top K results
can you understand this line
see
suppose this is the question
what are the prerequisites for ML course
and how long it is
now what we have done is
we have chunked all our campus X
documents
and put all the documents in vector store
now
for this question
we already know
that 101 and 103
are the correct answers
so in a way
for this question
the two correct documents
are document number 101
and document number 103
now what happened
when I
sent this question to my retriever
and I told you
that you fetch K is equal to 5
documents
so he fetched these documents
101, 102
104, 105
105, 106
now
you tell me
that in this particular scenario
how much is the recall
can someone tell me
what is the recall
based on this definition
you can tell me very easily
these are my correct
documents and these are my retrieved
documents so can you
calculate the recall
read this definition
so of all the correct relevant items
that exist
how many correct documents are there
2, how many did the system retrieve
in its top K results only 1
the answer is
1 by 2
basically my recall is 50%
ideally it should be 100%
it can't be more than 100
it can't be less than 0
so recall at the rate K
means this
so if you want to judge
whether the system is working properly
then there is one
very good way to judge it
that you can retrieve its recall at K
which I have calculated
and shown you
besides this there are other things
there is precision
you can also retrieve rank
but for now
let's keep it simple
what is our success criteria
recall at the rate K
ok
so did you understand the discussion
what are we doing
we are evaluating our retriever
and to evaluate
what is the success criteria
that we have defined that we will calculate its recall
after that what was the next thing
that we have to make a data set
so we made that
which you can see on the screen
this is the data set
what we did in this data set
that we
50, 100
such questions
which users can ask
in the future
when our chatbot will be live on the website
so here we tried to
cover all the cases
edge cases, difficult questions, easy questions
random questions
all kinds of questions
we made a data set
these are the questions
and then we made a human expert
we told him
take this question
and then go to our vector database
and find out
out of all the documents
which document has the right answer
of this question
so in a way we are making
our golden data set
ok
so we did this for 50, 100 questions
our data set is ready
is there any problem till here
is it clear
now see
what we did here
we defined an evaluation method
evaluation method is very simple
here we
programmatically
will determine
how much is our recall
very simple
what we will do
we will pick up 50 questions
and send it
to our retriever
ok
only to retriever
not to retriever
so what we did
we picked up this first question
and sent it to retriever
and retriever's K is 5
ok
so what retriever did
for this first question
for Q1
he took out these 5 documents
ok, then we sent the second question
then for the second question
he took out these 5 documents
same for third, fourth and fifth
so for every question
we retrieved the documents
now see
I have
original correct answer
and I also have
retriever
which documents he took
so now what I will do
on per row basis
or per question basis
I will calculate recall
for the first question
if you see
my retriever
found 101
so total was 101
and we found 101
so in this case our recall is 100% 1
second one if you see
101 and 103
he also found 101
and couldn't find 103
so in this case it is 0.5
and we will calculate for every question
and in the end
we will average this whole quantity
and by averaging
we will get our recall at the rate k
on our whole data set
ok
now this quantity
is telling us
how successful our retriever
is in fetching relevant documents
so you understood
this whole thing
basically what we did
we defined the evaluation method
we wrote a program
to do this whole work
and
we ran
evaluated the result
and 67% of our recall came
now what we will do
we will go and study those cases
where our recall is very bad
and after analyzing
those questions
we will not try to improve
our model
in this case retriever
now what can you improve in retriever
you can do many things
first of all
you can improve your embedding model
maybe your embedding model
is not able to capture semantic meaning
if you want you can
do expansion of the query
you can not send the question that user directly asked
first you will expand that question
through an LLM
and then you will send that question to retriever
that can be one thing
you can increase the value of k
now we have done k is equal to 5
so you will try k is equal to 10
or you can try re-ranking
it can be
your top 10 was there but
not in top 5
so you put a re-ranker
so the thing which was at 8 came to 3
so now you can see better results
so this is how you do
a component level
programmatic
eval
so this was the example
how to run a programmatic eval
and in this process
you might have learnt something
or you might have read it before
how do you evaluate a retriever
recall at the rate k
so
let me know if you understood
this whole thing
it is not going too deep
just giving you information from top to top
but I hope you understood the point
that how you can
carry out
the evaluations in a programmatic way
so think and tell me did we need
a human to evaluate
the retriever
did you think that
we should bring a human to check
or did we do our work through the program
I guess you are understanding
that if we are able to do a program
then why should we bring a human in the picture
humans are costly, we will have to pay salary
so what I will do is
I will
answer the questions, some people are asking questions
and after that
we will move to the next one
sir but in this evaluation
we cannot identify if thinking was right
if chunking was right
yes, no
it is not for chunking
for chunking there has to be some other eval
but this was strictly
for retriever's output quality
how will it know
about which doc is relevant
document, is it based on
score
no Archit, here we are
fetching exact document IDs
we are matching
things with IDs
we are not matching
the string hidden inside IDs
we are talking about ID level
I will have to make
this one data set
which chunk is relevant for query
we will have to do this manually
yes, no, no, this will be done by a human expert
how do we decide
the number we choose
yes, precision
at rate k can be one aspect
as I said
you have to see things from multiple aspects
for now
tell me one thing
my only goal of teaching this
was to show you
how programmatic
evaluation method works
so did you understand this
programmatic
method
how evaluations are carried out
I had told this in previous class
but that example was simple
this is a proper example
which you will do in future
is it clear
are you confused
at this point
if you are confused
you can spend some time here
he is doing it slowly
and this
you can see
the result
if you have
any doubts
here
I will wait for
one or two minutes
I am still confused
about how relevancy is seen
how is it seen
there can be many aspects of relevancy
one aspect is
all the right documents
from those
how many you can fetch
in vector database
that is one aspect of relevancy
second aspect of relevancy could be
all the documents
you brought
were not useful
third aspect is
all the documents
were they properly ranked
or not
so we are covering one aspect
all the actual relevant documents
who told us this
that person told us
who created golden dataset
related to this question
there is only one document
in our vector database which is 101
related to this question
there are only two documents 101 and 103
now if you
bring both of them
then you are getting the most relevant information
half if you bring one
then you will get half
relevant documents
if you bring neither of them
then you will get zero relevant documents
so we are defining
relevancy in this way
Dev Priya is saying
golden docs are created by humans
so this is not completely
programmatic
any eval
is programmatic
human based or model
is generated depends on
when we execute it
run it
then who is running it
golden dataset is a separate activity
execute
run
extract scores
who is doing this
this discussion is on the basis of this
obviously golden dataset is created by a human
human
it got a little confusing
just give me one second I am turning on the light
sir is there a way to evaluate our chunking strategy
I am not able to remember any direct metric
give me some time
I will figure it out and tell you
meanwhile we move forward
next
I want to show you one more example
where
this whole evaluation
is carried out by a human
so should we move on to the next
time
so should we move on to the next time
okay
so
so this is
the second example I am telling you
and in this case you will notice
that your
whole execution
of evaluation pipeline is
carried out by a human
okay
so let's assume
that again we have a chart bot
on campus
x website
and this is a general sort of
chart bot with which you can ask any kind of questions
when is the next course
launching, what is the fee of the next course
certificate will be available or not
course validity how much is there you can ask
general sort of chart bot
track chart bot obviously
will answer our documents
okay
now we have to evaluate this chart bot
that whether it is working properly or not
okay
and we
safety
and operations part are not evaluated
we are evaluating
application quality part
the quality of the answer
that when
any user asked a question
the answer he got was it helpful or not
we are evaluating this
okay
so our task our target is
our whole application
not one component
not one workflow the entire application
and our task
is to evaluate
its
helpfulness
okay
helpfulness means
your answer was accurate
its tone was right
and the answer was complete
this is what defines
helpfulness
so here also what you have to do first
is to define a success criteria
now here you will see
that to define a success criteria
is very tricky because what you are doing
you are
evaluating the whole application
you are evaluating on the thing that
whether it is helpful or not
how would you define a metric for this
the answer is there is no correct metric
this will vary business to business
so what we did
we defined a kind of
rubric
according to campusx
defined a criteria
of helpfulness
on 1 to 5
if we are giving 5 it means
that the answer
from the chat bot
is first of all correct
accurate
complete and in the right tone
3 means
partially helpful
1 means not helpful
so this is our kind of
success criteria we defined
after that what we did
we built a data set
you need a data set in evaluation
so what we did
we did
we made a chat bot
of 50-100
questions
a data set
where we again
from a coverage point of view
thought to put everything
normal questions, difficult
questions, edge cases
random questions
whatever my user can ask
I tried to put a representation
of that in this data set
now in this data set
we need to pay attention to
that there is only one column
which is the question that is being asked
to the chat bot
how long is the ML course
is the ML course right for me if I already know python
what's the fee for the DL course
do I get a refund if I drop out midway
can I pay fee in installments
we took out 50 samples
and put them in this data set
after that
next is define an evaluation method
now here
that the helpfullness
we need to figure out of this application
can you programatically
measure it
can you write a program
which
program tells us
automatically that
this chat bot is helpful
is it possible or do you feel
that it is very nuanced
and you need human judgment
what do you feel
can you write a program
write some piece of code
which will evaluate it and tell you
that yes this chat bot
is 70% helpful
90% helpful
or do you feel that
it is more nuanced
and you need human judgment
just let me know
you can do it with a program
or it is a very difficult task
and here human is required
I guess you can understand
so here
what you do
your evaluation method
becomes human
basically you need a human
now what you do
you run the model
basically you trigger your evaluation pipeline
how does the pipeline work
that you
pick up each question
and send it to your chat bot
what does chat bot do
chat bot generates answers
after that you
assign a person
and you give
these instructions to that person
see these instructions
see this question
see this answer
and give a grade
then pick up the next question
send it to chat bot
get an answer
ask the person
to see this question
and give an answer
based on the rubric that we have defined
same you do
for the entire dataset
now generally what you do
you make more than one person sit
like this is your grader A
this is your grader B
can someone think and tell
what can be the benefit of making more than one person sit
we are understanding the work
of making one person sit
we are trusting the judgement
what can be the benefit of making two or more
people sit
one straight forward
benefit is that if
your both graders
grading
is not
matching on many questions
then what can you
conclude from this
think and tell
make two people sit
show the answer of chat bot
one person says I will give 2 marks
the other person says I will give 4 marks
so they are differing again and again
what can you conclude from this
one thing you can understand from this
that there is some ambiguity
in your rubric
which you have defined the criteria
there can be a problem in that
so many times what is done
more than one grader is made to sit
and find this rubric
if they are agreeing
it means this
instruction is pretty clear
if they are disagreeing
then the above instruction is ambiguous
because of that both are confused
and this type of numbers are coming
so I wanted to cover this point
so I kept this grader here
but for now you can assume that there is only one human
who is doing all the evaluations for you
and finally
what will you do
you will
take out the average
and you will know
what is your helpfullness score
and who is the reason for this
because of your human
so this is a very simple scenario
where in human picture
your evaluation pipeline
is carrying out the entire end to end
so again
very simple example
just wanted to show you
how it comes in human picture
here I want to clear one more thing
that
in LLMEval
humans
do not do evaluations in one way
they do evaluations in more than one way
this method I told you is the most
simple method
that by looking at the answer of chatbot
it is giving a score
this is the most simple evaluation that humans do
apart from this
there are some other things that humans perform
there are some other type of evaluations that humans perform
how many of you have heard the name of red teaming
red teaming
is basically a situation
where a group of
individuals, humans
intentionally
attack a LLM based system
and try to figure out
where the system is breaking
so whenever these big LLMs
are launched, there are
red teaming teams
which try to
break the system
and when the system breaks, the data is taken out
and sent back to the development team
and it is fixed
so red teaming is also a kind of evaluation
that humans perform
but it is a different kind of evaluation
which is different from what we have read
second, in one more type of evaluation
humans help
AB testing
suppose you have two versions of chatbots
you put both in production
and test them AB
and you have told the users
that you have to rate
how is the experience so far
in which the rating is getting better
you select that version
and deploy it to the entire region
so what is happening here
your users are
evaluating
your application in production
so this is also a kind of evaluation
that humans perform
but it is a different kind of evaluation
which is different from what we have read
so you have just read the grading and rating
which we have seen in the flow chart
another kind of
evaluation is done by humans
when they make golden data sets
some time ago someone asked a question
that when we were doing the programmatic
there was a need for humans to make golden data sets
so that is also a kind of
evaluation
if I am going and telling
that for this particular question
for this particular question
here the answer is hidden
so I am performing
a kind of evaluation
so another type of evaluation
is when humans come in the picture
and define golden data sets
and rubrics
and the last one is human in the loop
sometimes there are so many complex cases
where you
don't trust only programmatic
or LLM based evaluations
in some complicated cases
you pass judgment
to humans
and actually human is also in the picture
if LLM is not handling
or programmatic checks are not handling
or some threshold is being formed
a grey area is being formed
so you pass on the responsibility to a human
and human gives you
the answer based on his judgment
so human in the loop is also
a kind of evaluation which comes in the picture
so in nutshell
humans perform
5 types of evaluations
in the world of LLM
rating and rating
which I have shown above
red teaming, A-B testing in production
golden data set creation
and human in the loop
this thing is clear
how humans are coming in the picture
and working
is this clear guys
we didn't read any rocket science
we are just doing it from a coverage point of view
this was simple
I don't think there was much here
so we have read
two evaluation methods
programmatic
and human
now quickly
tell me
what is the biggest
disadvantage of human based evaluation method
what is the advantage
quickly tell me
first of all
what is the advantage
what is the biggest advantage
when you
use a human based
evaluation application
then what is the biggest advantage of it
what are the benefits humans are bringing
yes
their judgment is reliable
if you are hiring a
person from a salika
then you will trust his judgment
a human brain can easily
figure out this thing
in comparison to a machine
so it is much more reliable
in comparison to some program or LLM
so reliability is very high
trust is more in this system
but
the disadvantage is
can you tell me what is the disadvantage
bringing humans in the picture
the biggest disadvantage is cost
you
have to pay to hire
people
that is the biggest downside
and that is why if your application is
at scale
millions of users are using it
then for evaluation most likely
you can't use humans
it would be costly
ok
so
what if
there is a scenario
where we can't use
a programmatic thing
because the thing we want to evaluate
is very ambiguous
such as we want to evaluate how helpful
a chart board is
so we can't use a programmatic
check but at the same time
we can't hire humans because
humans are costly so what is the alternative
what is there between
programmatic and human
which can be used
which has the qualities of programs
and humans
right, I guess you understood
the answer is LLMs
which is our third category
when you
use LLMs for evaluation
this
is the third category
and this is the most useful category
if you use it properly
and that is why you will see
that most of the LLM evaluation pipelines
which are made
they are mostly
based on LLMs
the evaluation method is
model graded or you can say
LLM graded
and the technique used
which is a very popular technique
which you will read a lot in this course
is called LLM as a judge
you use LLM like a judge
to evaluate something
and now I will show you
an interesting example use case
ok
so the discussion till here
is it clear
should we move on to the third case study
this one would be interesting
the last one would be interesting
I know the human one was very basic
ok
so let's move on to the
third one
so before case study I will create
a setup
setup is that I am a
website and youtube channel
which
prepares for UPSC
you must know UPSC
right, India's most difficult exam
is called, you crack this exam
and become an IAS officer
and do you know
what is the pattern of UPSC exam
what are the stages
have you done it, do you have any pain
or pain here, how many rounds
are there in UPSC exam
no one knows
here
prelims, mains
and interview
so there is prelims
then who pass
they have to give a mains exam
and then comes the interview
and after that you have to select
prelims if I am not wrong
is MCQ based
correct me if I am wrong
prelims MCQ based
right
mains is subjective
you have to write subjective answers
that is correct right
ok, setup is
that our website
is called campusx
UPSC
ok
and what we do is
we prepare for UPSC
both prelims and mains
ok
over time we realized
that
what we can do is
we can conduct
an automated
test
in which we, means for prelims
it is easy to conduct automated test
because it is a MCQ based exam
anyone can easily conduct this
for mains
it is difficult to conduct an automated test
because the answers
are subjective
which means to evaluate the answers
you need subject matter experts
now our problem is
that lakhs of students come to our youtube channel
and our exam can give lakhs of students
so for me
it is a big earning opportunity
I can earn a lot of money
the only problem is
that if say 10,000 students
sit in our mock test
then we have to
evaluate the subjective
paper of these 10,000 students
now think
that how many subject matter
experts we need
and we have to
pay these subject matter experts
on a per paper evaluation basis
so my profitability has decreased
but suddenly
a company came to me and said
that we have made a platform
on that platform
you can send many students
we have a LLM based
system
which on the basis of your defined rubrics
can perform
the evaluation of the students
and you have to
pay a fraction of a cost
so do you think
it makes business sense for me
to use this platform
right, it is very simple
logical
so we have to make this platform
means we have made this platform
now we have to evaluate it
this is our task
have you understood the setup guys
have you understood the setup
so this is the platform
which UPSC conducts mock
exam
and gives the evaluation
now whether the system is working
or not, we have to evaluate it
at scale
humans cannot come in the picture
through LLMs
so this is what we are going to do
next
so
ok
first of all
same flow
we have to define our target
and task
our target is
that the application we have made
we have to evaluate it
whether it is checking the papers
properly or not
like human experts
that is our task
now here
can you tell me
what can be the success criteria
what is the success criteria here
if in the case of chatbot
it was helpfulness
before that in the case of retriever
it was
recall at the rate k
so in this case
in this particular platform
what is the success criteria
what does success look like
when will we consider this system as successful
according to you
think a little and tell me
I want you to spend some time
and think and tell me
that this system
is doing the right thing
what will it depend on
it is evaluating the papers properly
what is the accuracy of
yes there can be an aspect
accuracy, but what is the accuracy of
what is the accuracy of
look here multiple perspectives
can be true
the question I am asking you
in that there can be multiple
answers
I just want to know
what are you thinking
yes, Harry said similarity score
Harry can you tell me
what is the similarity
let me tell you
I am actually asking
a little vague question
ambiguous question
there can be multiple
answers
let me tell you
what is the success criteria
our platform's success criteria
will be that
if my platform
evaluates
UPSC's answers
exactly
as human experts
do
then I would say
that my platform is successful
do you agree to this
I am saying it again, listen and tell me
if my platform
evaluates papers exactly
as a human expert does
then I will agree that
my platform is successful
I can deploy it, launch it
I can earn money from it
do you agree to this
I guess most of you would agree
that if our platform evaluates papers
as humans then our work is done
so this is our success criteria
in this particular scenario
are we on the same page
I agree
that there can be some other success criteria
but this is also a good success
criteria
the success criteria is
that is our platform
able to evaluate papers as humans
this is our success criteria
I am not telling you the exact metric
I have only told you the success criteria
I will tell you the metric later
now
based on our success criteria
we have to build a data set
now an interesting thing starts from here
first of all
what we will do
is we will
define a rubric
for a while
let's assume that our UPSC
has a paper
it has 3 questions
only 3 questions
how many can be there
let's assume that there are 3 questions
first question is
ethical governance is impossible without
administrative accountability discussed
second question is
examine the role of the governor
in central state relations
tenth question is
federalism in India is more cooperative than competitive
critically analyzed
now
what I did
I brought an expert
who evaluates very well
and I told him
just tell me
which dimensions
should I check
what all
will be written in the answer
I will consider it a good answer
so the expert defined
these 4-5 things
he said that if in the answer
we are talking about governance and accountability
then the answer is good
if the answer
explains the link between them
then the answer is good
if it gives mechanisms then the answer is good
if it cites examples
then the answer is good
if it's a balanced conclusion then the answer is good
so basically what I am doing
I am defining a rubric for each of my questions
so for each of my questions
I have defined 5 rubrics
for each of my questions
if I get 5 dimensions in the answer
then I will consider it a good answer
so this is my rubric
this is not the data set guys
this is not the data set
no
this is a rubric
which can evaluate a question
now
how will the data set look like
the data set will look like this
in the data set
answer id
what question's answer is that
what's written in the answer
here without a summary
suppose here
exact answer
here student's exact answer is written
and then
who has evaluated this answer
this is by a human evaluator
by the way we are creating our golden data set
golden data set is being
created by a human evaluator
and this is
50 to 100 rows
so we didn't need to evaluate
more papers
we just had to evaluate 50 to 100 papers
we just brought one subject matter expert
he has evaluated 50 to 100 papers
or 50 to 100 answers
I will give him 50 to 100
answers
so that you understand
that it was not a big deal
so this guy came
he saw which answer is this
which question's answer is this
he read the answer
and then
on the basis of this rubric
he saw this is the answer of question 1
he put check marks
first point is covered, second is covered, third is covered
fourth is covered, fifth is covered
so I am giving him 13 out of 15
then he saw
next one, some other student
wrote the same answer of question 1
so he did the first one partially
second one was not there, third one was not there
so I will give him 4
are you getting my point?
how we are creating a golden data set
we defined a rubric
then we conducted some papers
we took out some answers
and we are performing an evaluation
on the basis of rubric
so this is basically
how a human would evaluate
a UPSC
mains paper
I guess you can understand it
so this became my golden data set
guys if you have any problem till here
if you don't have any problem then say
I can understand it, just write why
and I would understand
that you can understand it till here
then I will move ahead
ok till here
simple? ok
so we are here
we made this
now
what we have to do
we have to define an evaluation method
now one thing is clear
you also tell me
do you think
we can evaluate these papers programmatically
is there a way
that we can evaluate
that LLM
basically
the answer that the user has written
we can put it in some python code
and compare it with human
with our evaluation
and we can tell
no, not really
and we don't want to use human because obviously it's costly
so there is only one way
that way is that we will use LLM
ok, so evaluation method
is set that it is a LLM
now what we will do is run this model
ok
we will run this evaluation
and what is the simple meaning of
running the evaluation
that
we will basically
bring an LLM in picture
and we will give it some instructions
what is the instruction? this is the instruction
we are telling our LLM
you are
grading a UPSC mains
answer against an evaluation
rubric
then we will tell it a question
from where will the question come
question
we will extract it from the question paper
we will tell how much marks the question is
and for that question
we will tell the exact rubric
basically we are taking out data from here
we are taking out the question
how many marks the question is
and we are telling it the exact rubric
ok
after that we are giving it
aspirant answer
which the user has written
basically this quantity
we are giving this quantity
that the user has written this answer
now what are we writing next?
we have written a prompt
ok
and we have written
that tell us
what are the dimensions
that the user has answered
and how many marks you are giving it
and give a reasoning
of 2 sentences justification
why you have given it so many marks
now
we are writing
the answer
why you have given it so many marks
now what is happening
that every answer we are getting
which the user has written
and it is going to this chatbot
this LLM
and our LLM is giving us this
see
for a particular answer
of a particular question
we are getting how many marks that LLM has given
for a particular answer
for a particular question we are getting
how many marks that LLM has given
and we are doing this for all the answers
ok
and along with that
we are comparing it with
that on that question
how many marks that user has given
by human
now I have
side by side information
for the same answer
how many marks have been given by human
by LLM
based on the same rubric
both have seen the same rubric
LLM is also seeing the same rubric
and how both
are marking
now tell us what is our goal
at this point
what should be our goal
what is the success criteria
what is the
success criteria
in both these columns
our success criteria is hidden
if both these columns
are very similar
then what does it mean
it means
the way human
is evaluating papers
our LLM is also
evaluating it
it means our system is working
on these 50 questions
at least
these 50 answers at least
so now can you tell me
can you give me one metric
these are success criteria
they should be similar
but tell me a metric
can you define one metric
tell me something
is there a metric
perfect, Himanshu gave a perfect answer
MAE
what is MAE's full form
mean absolute error
what will we do
we will subtract
13-12
plus
4-8
8-8
plus for 50 answers
and divide by 50
suppose
2.3 came here
can you tell me what 2.3 means
suppose answer 2.3 came
after applying this formula
what does it mean
it means on an average
my LLM
while evaluating
answers
is deviating from human
it is deviating from 2.3
now your whole goal
will be to bring this number down
to zero
because if this number is zero
it means your LLM
is evaluating
the answers exactly
like a human does
that is your success criteria
now your whole goal is
to bring this number down
now you can do many things
you can bring a better LLM in the picture
you can change the system prompt
you can change
the rubric
you can do changes in the rubric
so you will do many things
in the loop but you have an evaluation
mechanism
with which you can define
how
I can make such a system
which will evaluate
UPSC answers exactly like a human does
is the point
clear guys
is the point clear
we just saw
how LLM as a judge works
with a relatable
kind of example
was it interesting
it took a lot of effort
to make this example trust me
the examples
which were coming to my mind before this
they were very boring, vanilla
then finally while exploring
I reached this
conclusion that this might be an interesting
Aman is asking
how will this happen in post deployment
as we don't have the criteria
during inference
good question Aman
we will discuss this in the next class
when we will study online vs offline
evaluation
there I will discuss this point
it is just a topic for the next class
is there any question
at this point
there is some sense
of things
till now you were
happy with LLM based applications
are you
feeling a little change
now you are thinking
like a production engineer
who is figuring out
that will our application
work properly
and then deploying it
can you sense this change
inside you
in comparison to before
it is not only about building a LLM based application
that is the easy part
the difficult part is to make sure
it will work each time
everywhere that is the challenging part
good
if yes then great
that is why I am spending more time
in the theory
but don't worry
we will see all these things practically
so don't worry
whatever I am telling you how to create
golden data set
how to run the evaluation pipeline
we will do all this
don't worry
so one last thing
we are covering in today's class
and that is
there is a term
sometimes it is asked
that is why we are discussing
you already know about it
so two terms are asked
or discussed
you can read it online
reference based evaluation
and reference free evaluation
what is it
both are defined
I will tell you first
reference based
evaluation
so reference based evaluation
is an evaluation where you have
a reference
unknown correct answer
or the key thing
a correct answer must contain
written down in advance for each test case
you grade by comparing the output
against the reference
tell me quickly
the last three examples
we have seen
programmatic
where we evaluated retriever
human
where we evaluated chatbot's helpfulness
and llm as a judge
where we made upsc
can you tell me
which of these evaluations
are reference based
which means we already knew the correct answer
which
methods
we covered
reference based
where we knew the answer
answer
we know in golden dataset
tell me quickly
the one we discussed
we discussed the one with upsc
we already knew the answer in his golden dataset
yes or no
yes we knew right
here if you see
here
we are telling
what mark human is giving
This is the correct answer
What is the correctness here?
We want to evaluate like a human
So who is correct?
Human's evaluation
So human's evaluation is for every answer
That in this answer, human has given so many marks
So you also try to give as many marks as possible
This is what we are telling the system
So this is an example of reference based evaluation
Similarly, if I go up
And see this one
The retriever example
Here for this question
I have already told you that the answer is in the 101 document
For this question, I have already told you that the answer is in 101 and 103
So again I am defining the correct thing here
So this is also an example of reference based
Whereas if you talk about the human one
So what is our data set here?
Here our data set is
See here
Here our data set is simply the list of questions
This is what we are giving to the human
We are giving this question to the chatbot
The chatbot is answering
We are asking to evaluate the answer and tell us if it is correct or not
But there is no correct answer in the data
What the human is doing is
It is reading this rubric
And then on the basis of its judgment, it is deciding
What should be the difference between 1 to 5?
There is no correct answer defined here
Here we are relying on human judgment and defining this rubric
So this type of evaluation is called
Reference free evaluation
See here it is written
In our case, there was a rubric
Which I told you exactly
So going forward, will you be able to classify
If I show you an evaluation pipeline
So will you be able to tell if it is reference free or reference based
Simply you have to ask if the correct answer is given in your golden data set or not
If it is not given, it is a reference free one
If it is given, it is a reference based one
Simple, this is the difference
That is why I had to teach you this
That is why I gave you the three examples that I gave you earlier
I deliberately took an example in the human one
That there was no reference there
Is it clear guys?
Will you be able to tell the difference?
Okay
So yeah
That is all we had to cover today guys
I mean there were a couple of topics more
But I felt that we could not cover
One very important topic is left
Offline versus online evaluation
So far whatever we are reading is kind of
Offline evaluation
When the system goes into production
It is not covered in the production
So it is not covered in the production
When the system goes into production
Even after that, evaluation is done
Which we call online evaluation
We have to read that next
So that was one topic which is left
So yeah
Based on the entire discussion
If you have any doubts, please tell me
How many people are left?
I will ask the same question again
I hope the class didn't get boring
Okay
Understood
We discussed two big points today
One big point is
Why do we need multiple eval pipelines?
We tried to understand that through many examples
And second is
We spent a lot of time on the three methods
Of LLM evaluation
That was it
The whole goal of today's class
Okay
Fine
So if you have any questions
You can ask
From what I recall
This session was to cover an overview
On Frontier LLM's evaluation
And then deep dive into LLM apps
Yeah, yeah
Actually, what happened if you remember
The first session I took
We were not happy
With the execution of the session
So I thought
Let's take that session again
So
I took that session in the last class
But it was not completed
So in a way, we are still
Covering the same first session
We are just doing it in more detail this time
So once this whole part is covered
Then we will
Go to LLM's evaluation
We will discuss benchmarks and all
And then we will move from
The next session to
Application evals
Which we are discussing now
We will do it practically
Everything is going as planned
It's just going a bit slower
Yeah, Shruti
I will export these notes
And I will give this to Sufal
And I will put it up on the website
By tomorrow
How many lectures will be taken?
Since this is my first time taking this course
I actually have no idea
How many lectures will be taken
But my goal is to finish it in July
Sir, can we say
Humans are reliable but
Relying on one
Induced bias
Yes, yes, I gave an example earlier
That we had kept more than one human evaluator
One reason I told you
That
Let's check the rubric
That there is no ambiguity in it
The second advantage is
That if one person is biased
Then the other person will neutralize it
That's why more than one evaluator is kept
So yeah
If yes, then what is a good head count?
Again, it depends on
The application that you are building
And the kind of resources that you have
Ideally, if you have free resources
Then you will try to use as much as possible
Sir, can this class be done from 7pm?
I mean, it can be done
Then I might not be able to take the class for two hours
Main issue is
I have a small baby
So
Basically, there are personal reasons
Nothing else
That's why it's a little difficult
If it ends at 8pm, then it's a good time for me to go back home
Otherwise
I don't have any problem
I can take the session at night
I might try 7-8.30
I will let you know
Let's let it go for a few days
Let this course happen once
And after that
Next, whenever we have some
Our next course will be
We can
Rediscuss the timing
Okay
Guys, last 2-3 minutes
If you have any questions, then ask
If you don't have any questions, then you can go
I guess there are no more questions
No, man
My Google I.O is happening in Bangalore
They invited me
And I was planning to go
To see 14th
But then
I thought
There will be a gap of 3-4 days
In the classes
So I cancelled it
Otherwise
I was going to be in Bangalore from 14th to 17th
So we could have done the meetup for a day
Now
Unfortunately
What about Gurgaon meetup?
The main problem is
This new thing
This insider one
It's been a month
We are trying to stabilize it
If you have any feedback
We are trying to improve it
So we are not trying any new things
That is why meetups are postponed
But once
We feel that we have
Set up the flow
We have to take so many classes in a week
The course is going on well
So we will do these things
Currently I cannot give you a date on any meetup
But
Definitely on our list
Okay Shruti
I will upload both the medias
Okay guys
I will close the session
I just hope you
Understood things
If you didn't understand
You can watch the recording again
And if you still didn't understand
Then in the next class
You can ask me whatever doubts you have
Okay
Bye Good Night